Palestinian journalist mohammed al chief
has been on hunger strike for more than
90 days leaving him near death
he's one of hundreds of Palestinians
held by Israel in administrative
detention which means they're imprisoned
without charge or trial going on hunger
strike is one way prisoners can protest
it's an extreme and risky measure but al
peek isn't the first to try it in 2013
30,000 California prisoners held a
two-month long hunger strike to draw
attention to the state's use of
prolonged solitary confinement one
prisoner died during the strike which
was called off after state lawmakers
agreed to hold public hearings on the
use of long term isolation in prisons
but this wasn't the longest hunger
strike in recent history in 2000 Turkish
prisoners carried out a death fast to
oppose the isolation cells where many
political prisoners were kept over the
next six years 122 of them died and many
others were left permanently disabled
from the effects of starvation most
recently in 2015 student activists
jailed for protesting in favor of
education reform in Myanmar went on a
hunger strike to demand their freedom
and the freedom of every political
prisoner in the country they ended the
strike only when the military government
that jailed them lost the national
election but many of the students still
remain behind bars and then there are
the prisoners held on American territory
at Guantanamo Bay they've organized
hunger strikes in response to years of
imprisonment without charge or trial
prisoners on hunger strike hoped to
pressure governments to release them out
of fear of a fallout from a prisoner
dying so in response to these hunger
strikes many countries including the
United States will force-feed the
prisoners to keep them alive this is in
spite of the United Nations view that
forced feeding violates the prisoners
human rights force-feeding means
prisoners are fed through a tube
inserted into the nose they are
restrained and given drugs to prevent
the involuntary vomiting that can occur
if prisoners resist or something goes
wrong injuries can range from bloody and
broken noses to pneumonia
a collapsed lung or even death it's no
surprise then that the world Medical
Association says it's unethical for
doctors to participate in forced feeding
for many prisoners going on a hunger
strike is the only way to protest and
for al peek who's gone without food
longer than any other Palestinian
prisoner
it could mean protesting to the death